okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about language
completeness and consistency we have a
variety of items to discuss today some
of which are relevant for the now
largely closed version 12 okay starting
with URL and file functions right so
there's this maybe it would be open if
you easier if you open the file name
join rough page to understand this first
one there's this weird note that nobody
really knew what it meant and let's see
right so the last note file name joint
of name canonicalize is the file name
name making path name separators
appropriate for your operating system
so what that means is this exactly this
one behavior here so if you give it a
file name if you give it a path with
forward slash separator and your target
is Windows it'll change them to back
slashes which is kind of a bizarre thing
for file name joined to do I think well
there's something else to it well you
could do you know file names lit and
file name join if you need it no but
isn't that doesn't necessarily give you
a name it's bound remember Steven we
stumbled on this when you looked at the
file scheme and you wondered about this
as well I think that predates the
existence of filename expand which time
sure does and so I think we feel we
should delete that note and at some
point to get rid of that functionality I
don't think we should ever get rid of it
but what is file name expand
oh it's expand file name or so yes it's
the third
how do we end up with file name join and
expand file name because it's friend is
absolute file name so there's absolute
file name which is you know verifies the
you know that the file exists and expand
file name which you know gives you the
path that expand fire absolute file name
will test if it you know if it were to
go looking for it also Alan doesn't
absolute file name do things like
realize that it the path is referring to
a soft link or has a soft link in the
middle and it will turn it into and it
will resolve that and tell you what it
actually is sounds right
we should check there does that but okay
so expand file name so one of the things
that this is doing is making a file name
suitable for a foreign operating system
this does not have that capability right
yeah but I mean it doesn't really work
that way I mean what do you again what
what what do you you can do if you want
to make it suitable to an operating
system is to use that first first X
sorry first what'swhat's the inverse a
file name join filming but finally
first you do a file name split continue
to a file name join with the list
argument and the operating system option
that's the only reliable way to do it
wait a minute so file name right the
thing so I want the file name join with
one argument do that I mean it seems not
particularly profound but but but that
Act doesn't do that so for example if
you were on Windows and you had a
separator with back slashes and you said
file name join of you know a slit a
backslash B and you gave it an operating
system goes to you know UNIX it would do
nothing so what what this behavior is
really what what that what this behavior
actually is is it takes file names which
use slashes and converts them to the
target operating system which back when
we had three standards because classic
Mac OS used colons and Windows uses back
slashes was perhaps because windows to
use back slashes yes
does it accept forward slashes I thought
it did sort of it depends exactly how
you but to our file operations except
forward slashes they do don't they I
[Music]
think so well I think I mean if you look
at it this first example on the left try
name join them and they're really two
operating systems there you need to know
what intended operating system is of the
first filename argument and then you
have the option and i don't know whether
the option refers to the original or to
the intelligence target so that's why i
say that finem split followed by file
name join and each having its operating
system option is what do you listen
listen look the thing we nearly need to
figure out is for Windows which is the
only remaining operating system that
doesn't have the standard UNIX /
convention right
they're forgiving our our filename
operations with respect to giving unix
file names for Windows if if we somehow
managed to make that work and sadly my
Windows I used to use a Windows machine
part of the time but for the last two
years that's basically been it's been
impossible to set it up correctly so I
haven't been using it um but which is
really a shame um but um so I I don't
know whether I mean I just think we
should make sure that our unix-style
file name conventions work properly on
Windows and this issue is sort of moot
except for interacting with external
programs and in interaction with
external programs the weird hack of
having filename join of one argument
convert file names seems a bit
unnecessary so I agree that it should be
undocumented but more important is to
make sure that we do sensible things on
Windows with UNIX style file names that
fair let's go find that out okay yeah
I'm firing up a Windows VM so I can do
at least a quick test you know okay all
right okay let's move on okay so then
the second point is right so one of the
things with this newly expanded
capabilities of file name who functions
to take file URLs is that so that solves
a problem of taking a file URL and
turning it into a path that you can you
know give your shell or give you no
local file yes but it I this are the
only reason I added this is that we have
that file named split support which we
are now removing and so I will remove
that code before it even makes it into
12-point oh because there's no point in
adding code that is already obsolete so
if we agree to undocumented string case
for file name join
then I will remove that code to handle
file name join of a single URL file you
are right but but but right you still
have code I'm not talking just about
file name split right I mean you did
like expand file name takes a file URL
and converts it to an equivalent and
there's maybe some sort of fake support
in file name join which you know needs
to be done better that's point three but
before we go on to that so expand file
name can solve the problem okay I have
this mirrored file URL how do I convert
it into a file name that I can give to
low-level file functions but what solves
the reverse problem I have a file name
and I want to construct a file URL for I
mean I don't know why me
[Music]
you know maybe yes I mean that's
probably the question why would you want
to do this I mean you you would have to
just go use standard URL path and you
build functionality so I mean if you
have a finally we have an example of
that yeah I mean you if you have a file
if you have a path name you first do a
file name split and then you set the
then you use that without that's the
path component in a URL build I mean
it's it's it's a lot of work I mean it's
if we need if we want to convert path
names to file URLs then we would need
such a function just for convenience
right I mean right so you know my sense
of the history is the reason we started
even supporting converting file URLs to
file names is because you know you used
file URLs in
your local object thing here right so
suppose somebody you know takes you know
takes a local object to file URL and you
know converts it to a file and then
maybe wants to go back to a file URL
yeah I mean you could always say local
object of paths and it will do it for
you because doesn't track the existence
of anything so probably that function is
local object slight misuse but it will
certainly return file URL okay what are
you proposing that local object of URL
yeah if you have a path name as a string
person and you want to file URL so you
say local object off so he's suggesting
if you were to type in right now local
object of you know ed CEFs tab / @ c FS
oh yeah that won't work yes so that that
works okay while it returns a local
object yes and you know you extract the
you could do to where you can replace
the head local object but you already
know prior URL to local object
yes it's a bit weird why doesn't your
elevates atropos mode do the right thing
because because URL is just just
information right that's just the tip
and she's not using what it did here
does it actually work to open it that's
the password
it might depends on on how the the
operating system treats there
probably neither poeple on file colon
slash slash it didn't do anything here
didn't beep it didn't do anything
no so
not you not have a default application
to open it with oh right because it
doesn't know right you'd need something
with like an extension with like a TX
like that what is that but white with
with the file colon slash slash prefix
maybe that then has a proper mime type
right I think basically the operating
system doesn't know what to do with this
file type so you need something with
like a txt extension all right okay
where do I put it
technically you need one more slashes
for the at the beginning slashes for the
protocol in 1/4 yeah it's the operating
system doesn't know what to do with this
file yeah okay fine
I mean you by the way I mean this open
thing we should do better than that I
mean I'm actually surprised it doesn't
open your browser because the browser
knows about to do with five your eyes
okay so this is a bug in the way that
system open is interacting with URL well
I don't know that I would go that far I
mean since the purpose of system open is
to give this URL to the operating system
and it will do whatever does with it so
if you gave it something that it knew
what to do with like a txt file it would
open it in your text editor but it
doesn't have a file Association for dot
HD and it's not a HTTP so it's not
giving it to the browser okay
well okay so I don't know what we I this
seems wrong that this doesn't do
anything that it offers you an open
thing that that doesn't do anything
yeah I thought it would give you a beep
if because it shouldn't
I mean system open should know whether
the operating system was happy with it
or not but I mean we need to talk to Lou
and John on the Bell also sometimes
system open it if it doesn't work I mean
the normal way is to prompt you for the
program to to use what not on Mac okay
so but on Windows and Linux it will do
that yes I mean we are really at the
mercy of the of the of the operating
system here yeah all right so yeah I
guess my my question is are we okay with
needing to use URL at local object or
maybe well what were you suggesting
Roman that you could use URL
yeah you are possible Betsy that's even
less obvious okay that's interesting why
would it do that so look whatever system
open is doing and by the way for some
reason Mike what's another harmless file
that would exist here let's see if I can
find one I don't think there's nothing
profound in this
oh yeah so it opened I mean max probably
has its own way of telling what the file
is supposed to be so the question is why
did it work there because it figured out
that it was a text file
oh here yeah why did it not work in this
case
that's a good question which I do not
know the answer to so if you do file of
that work no that worked
okay that worked I think I didn't try
that one before so there's something
about the FS tab file that it may be
protected in some way oh binary right or
maybe because it actually has an
extension that's looking for a file
Association whereas password has no
extension so it's just the faulting to
text right okay anyway all right what do
we do let's see um yeah so this should
be doing the equivalent of system open
but when it fails when this happens
surely pressing that button should
generate a message rather than just
silently doing nothing like I said I was
pretty sure it's supposed to be bit you
I would expect a beep and not a message
that pops up wherever yeah okay let's
move on please yeah yeah okay can we go
onto this input file name question well
we did skip over the what could we skip
over the number three there suppose for
URL and file name join which what about
it so what are we doing that what do we
want to do that well it so right now I
think it only does it basically what
expand file name does
but what is it you already want it to do
is there ok if you open the email sweat
and do and read my comments then the
idea is that the normal argument the
filename join is a list and the first
argument of that list should allow for a
file scheme URL it does allow for cloud
object so I I will simply add that case
ok and if you have it if you still have
it open that file name join you might
just as well delete that note right now
so I can take care of that ok so now I
will delete the code to handle lonely
your file URL not inside a list okay
good all right so then dollar input file
name plus wolfram script yeah so you
just need to open the source yes oh oh
you didn't update today because I added
this unless unless I just imagined
committing it but hold on I I don't
haven't sake I only imagined committing
it ok now or do you want me to share no
why don't you commit and I'll pull it in
it may mama territory for something else
all right
what was that file input file name
I was meted okay right so previously
there there was this issue with
depending on in what mode you invoked
the the script in some modes that we use
get in other modes it would not use get
so in the modes where it used get it
would set dollar input file name and in
the other modes it would not this is
something that Garrett has now fixed in
version 12 so that no matter how you
invoke wolfin script okay okay the
execution of a Wolfman language script
through wolfram script okay I think
that's fine okay what does it do in the
case where let's see what does it do in
the case okay I see if you're just
running wolf from script from the
command line so for example if I just
say here wolfram script
right so that's interactive input so per
the documentation it should return the
null string okay okay fine so if it's a
hash bang what what happens if I do this
well from script first
oh yeah very good weird
okay control D is that right yes um
always been control D to help that oh
it's oh it's it's the shell you need to
you need to escape the the dollar sign
with just a backslash yes yes okay right
but if you if you had a file through
that you know yeah either food that WL
or food wls and you did Wolfram script -
file that name you would get dollar
input file name why are we saying at the
start of the execution isn't it during
the execution of Wolfram language I mean
what happens if that script calls
another script and then returns right so
if if that script gets another file then
during that yet dollar input file name
will be that second that reverts but
then that will revert okay so this isn't
quite right so it says during the
execution of a wolf language script
set to the absolute file name in which
the script is stored that right I think
that's straight during interactive input
or other forms of input or other forms
of input that do not involve a file name
that do not involve okay well actually
when input is not taken from a file
correct does not come from a file I mean
the one case where it's the word that's
potentially slightly ambiguous is write
in a notebook even if it's saved dollar
in tonight okay well it does not come
from an explicit it's not coming
directly from a file this is also or
comes from an interactive notebook
yes this is correct because if you if
you pipe in input or if you have an
interactive session it'll be empty okay
is the source wls file it it can be it
can be well if you're if you if it's you
know it can be a wls file but it doesn't
have to be yeah of a script file through
or from script absolute file name of the
script file okay yep
and add the twelve to the modified in at
the top and we'll be done
okay all right let's continue recursive
option for copy directory yeah I mean so
what's that yeah again there's something
missing but nevermind it's trivial just
go on
okay so first question yeah I mean why
isn't there a way to copy a whole
directory tree well directory well copy
the subdirectories yes
in fact it's yes so yeah I don't know
what happened to the added notes I look
for this guy but in fact the situation
is
copied is basically that copy file and
copy directory are the same function so
if you did copy file on the a directory
then without any warning
it would copy the whole directory see
what about if I say copy file and then
the destination is a directory well are
you saying the source it will cut I
believe it'll copy the hole no no I'm
saying the sources of file the
destination is a directory right then
I'll copy that one file into that
directory okay I don't think this is
properly documented that's what I would
expect it would do from a typical
operating system copy file but it's not
what's documented okay so that needs to
be looked at I mean if it says here
right there's nothing here that says
that it copies into the directory okay
so right can we fix that okay but I
think I think we have sort of more
serious issue again that you know cut
both copy file and copy directory sort
of you know silent delete read files and
directories interchangeably right okay
so that's fine but let's just document
it whatever it whatever it has been
doing if it is the same as what
operating systems typically do is well
it's not I I don't think there's what
operating systems typically do I just I
just tested it and it if you do a copy
file and this and file to is a directory
just to treat it as an existing file and
refuses to call me so it doesn't do it I
think that's wrong because I think you
need the functionality to take a file
and copy it into a directory that would
be very useful yes
yes so it should say somehow that if the
25/2 is an existing directory it will
copy in yes that is what it should say
and that it probably also makes sense
for cloud objects and local objects
because they can be done yes well if the
destination of file type file type if
the file type is directory then it's a
director otherwise if it's a files any
complaints about not operating if it's
none then it just does it and of course
I mean we could go on and have another
option that says whether it should
create intermediate missing directories
or not but don't know where we want to
stop right but okay so first thing is
somebody needs to so Roman and it I
maybe you could look at this and try and
come up with a you know details for how
this should work straightforward to me
um okay let's keep going here right so I
thought I mean we can certainly talk
about the next item the I thought or not
what's going to be here but I think
there enough people that we can talk
about this even without our node so if
you open up the right so this is about
this compiled code function so there was
a thread about this recently where I was
confused and then or no by why I was
getting what while why compiled function
was giving me something that was clearly
not matching its declared type and then
our node chimed in and said yes that
he's also confused by this so I think
okay well actually before we get to that
even on our live stream is asking a
couple of interesting questions okay um
first question is with Wolfram script
ever support remote kernels there's no
good reason it shouldn't hasn't been
looked at I mean Roman can you comment
on that
I mean if the KCM if the colonel
connection manager was here we would be
able to do that wouldn't we
yes I mean we could certainly set up
well
connection so SSH oh so I mean we have
the functionality and then oh there's
also the other case whether the chrome
is in the cloud and I think that they
support it right so that's already
supported right yes so we support cloud
kernels so basically right I mean III
don't know that this was anywhere on our
roadmap but right basically we would
meet
if by remote kernels he means you know
something from all that we would access
via SSH but whatever the remote kernel
capability is from from a front-end you
could expect to access kernels in the
same kind of way it's useful I mean it
would allow I mean I have no idea what
happens in well from script if you say
parallel you know you could be using the
parallel evaluate kernel provisioning
stuff but I have no idea what that will
do well well I mean that's different
right because there that it's the local
kernel that you're using that's going to
be launching those sub kernels however
it decides to do that yeah which is
different from you have no local kernel
and you need to SSH into some remote
machines you have a kernel to even start
doing anything which I mean is certainly
there are we can go ask our I mean he
should know whether that is even
feasible or not right okay so let's do
that I think um okay having a copy file
work between remote and local
directories with authentication etcetera
etcetera etcetera will be great I
thought we did have copy fire able to
really be in 12-point go with SCP and
SFTP support okay
copy directory should have options for
pattern exclusions like Linux CP
that's a reasonable suggestion actually
he's suggesting beyond that would be
better to mimic the AWS command-line
interface which I do not know yeah I
must know I mean there are several tools
force for copying tweeze like how sync
is another popular one which is all
these exclusion options and so I don't
know which one we should emulate well I
mean I don't think that necessarily yeah
I mean our sink has about 40 or 50
options right I mean I don't think we
want to go the arcing crowd at least not
literally but I think you know I don't
think we necessarily need to have a bug
for a bug you know reimplementation of
one of these standard tools as long as
we provide something that integrates
nicely with the language so right you
know you can specify exclusions as a
regular expression or string pattern or
you know whatever
what yeah and well I guess Roman and I
can look at this when we're since we're
already looking at this we can add this
to our let's define to think about copy
file and copy directory okay okay look
at this AWS thing whatever it is okay
what is this here right so this was so I
created a a very simple compiled
function that just rounds its argument
and right it claims to return a integer
64 but when you give that you the dollar
notes machine number
it sort of silently returns a big a you
know a
a big integer rather than something
that's a machine integer and so I was
very surprised by this and Tom said oh
there is this message but Stephen wanted
it off by default and then our note came
in sort of later in the third and said
you know yeah I think this also should I
also think this should be on by default
so you know me and our node green
agreeing it's not exactly like me and
Holly agreeing but it's certainly closer
to that end of the scale then you know
me and John agree so the issue is how
much noise there is associated with
using the compiler I mean I tend to
think that in this experimental phase of
using the compiler that it's probably
worth having it on by default all right
but I don't think that's the long term
story I mean right now it's because
there's so many ways to fail with using
the compiler that makes more sense to
have it on by default but what is this
even I don't even understand I don't
even understand it even approximately
what the heck it's doing here right I
mean so what is it supposed to do this
is supposed to just generate why it
takes so long I have no idea what the
heck is that problem and two days ago
build I wonder oh I wonder if this is if
it's trying if it needs to look at some
XML and this was the day that XML was
broken due to predation yeah due to a
momentary miss configuration on the
build machines okay all right so this is
supposed to take right so I'm creating a
function that takes a real 64 and rounds
into an integer yeah I know and it's not
doing correct type inference so it's
getting the wrong answer well now I'm
ready
the input that it can't possibly produce
the output right so well right because
well I suppose you can argue I don't
understand why it produces output in
this case I mean this is a specific
compiled function that has a specific
type declaration your input does not
match the type declaration what is this
it does oh it does right I gave it Matz
machine number oh I see it can't sit in
the result because you can't sit I
understand well then I kind of agree
that for the time being this message
should be on I mean I'm hoping that in
the future the message will not be on
anymore okay sorry I need to go to an
external meaning okay - right so this is
an email that came to me from I know not
where other way comment from Brian on my
live stream allowing exclusions based on
file properties such as date and size
will be useful in the copy I agree and
we probably have some pattern for that
in file name scan I mean whatever family
and scan is doing to pick the files that
it wants to consider is kind of a
perhaps a pattern for this yep okay
extensions to thread a nap thread
so yeah so I'm not sure exactly where
this came from but come from me from you
and Steven okay okay right so right now
map thread insists on lists right so you
can't even do right gee you can't have G
of whatever in in the second argument
and have it take up the different which
is annoying every now and then right
because you need to I don't know why
night doesn't work on associations I
don't think that would harm anything in
other words there's no ambiguity it map
thread will dig to a certain level and
it's not like it would do something
useful it's just gonna fail in this case
right right well yes right right but my
point is it's going to fail with any
head other than list no I understand it
but I what does it do right now in this
case that's really weird what it seems
to be doing why would it be doing that
oh yeah there we go okay it just fails
right so this is the suggested behavior
right and actually not now that I look
at what they're saying I'm not sure why
map thread with an association should
produce a list of results I guess I
didn't well let's take a look at what it
should do so map thread normally if that
was a list right if this was a list
right it needs to be a list of lists so
I think maybe if you get rid of the rule
okay so what do we think the analog of
that is here the the Association should
be which list are we seeing here we are
seeing the outer lists presumably well
what do we think we're seeing do we
think we're seeing the outer lists we
think that thing there is the outer list
yes I would think what the result should
be yeah K one no but isn't maps where is
just there but for cases where thread of
F of Arc collapses before sweat sees it
so I think what we are seeing is the
inner list because what you're really
trying to do is f of list 1/2 comma list
3/4 and if F intervenes before you to
thread of that then you use maps wet ok
so this would be the correct answer then
because that's using the inner list
becomes the outer container here right
no I don't think that's right I mean
right map thread takes the the right
that it it gives you a list and it takes
the maybe it's well we don't know what
had to use so we're using lists but
right it right it gives you the list of
results F of a right it takes the
corresponding elements from each sub
list and the basic usage yes right oh
and a clue it says map thread works on
Association objects what does the third
example down there what the heck why
does it work on that one inside the list
you out the outer element is a list not
right okay so and I think which makes
sense because I mean you're really
giving it a list of parallel arguments
so if it's if the outer thing is an
association what does it mean right and
oh and here the result is an association
okay which i think is probably correct
maybe I mean on the right hand side we
have a list of associations turning into
an association of lists oh no let's take
a look in this case here okay so now if
we say okay so clearly if we say B goes
to X and let's say C goes to Z should
yell that we'll say it's it will fail
right yep but this is the same issue as
in join across and in other functions to
what extent do you create you know
missing entries in the Association to
get what I'm saying like join across has
a whole elaborate way of doing that what
does merge do in this case or is this
not the merge what as much do for what
for that list of them right so if you do
that list comma F
what did that just do that merged okay
merged yes it merged everything that was
relevant so if I put in a see arrow W
here that will do that okay all right so
let's take at them take a look at the
matrix case I wonder if that'll give us
some insight into you know which list
we're seeing in the output there's an
example you can copy the second basic
example there well if we did the same
thing at level one we'll get a bunch of
lists in there okay so look I mean the
issue here is should an outer
Association does merge support and outer
Association
okay why doesn't merge support that one
would think should be able to do that
because it would put instead of F list
one two it would put there F of
Association P 1 Q 2 right I mean it's
conceivably it could work although I
think it would still have to return a
list why I mean because they're they're
sort of you know the transpose operation
built into this right no look at it the
if the outermost thing is an association
right I'm saying the keys don't match up
because why not you're just taking the
keys of the the macro objects here right
I mean but suppose I gave a or you're
saying the a would be the you would
return keys in terms of a B and C but no
no what I'm saying the result will be as
a arrow F of Association pro-1 Q arrow
to see
[Music]
see I think right I mean so it could
return an association but it wouldn't
involve P and Q why not what I'm saying
is the result should be a rof of
association pro-1 qrow - right comma B
arrow F of Association blah blah blah
yeah okay let's see but right that makes
sense I don't know why we're not doing
that okay so that's one cases merge
dealing with an outer Association rather
than outer lists and the other case so
the cases we're dealing with here are
map thread and merge with an outer
Association right and I don't see why
those shouldn't be made to work I think
that behavior is fairly easy to you know
fairly obvious um let us invest
that seems reasonable to me do we agree
with these outputs here
yeah I think so I think that list is
that in a list there so if we go down
multiple levels so for example if I were
to do this map thread and then this is
an association pro-1 qrow to
right then I should get
then the outermost thing will be an
association right
but in this example in the line before
you modified it it doesn't do the math
part right it should F should map all of
those associations on the right hand
side you are right that's not the right
thing yeah so it should be K 1 arrow F
of 1 K 2 where or F of 3
no the analog no that's not right
because here oh yeah I see there's a
problem there's a problem because the
map thread is mapping onto the naked
it's applying to the list 1 3 see what
I'm saying
mm-hmm whereas you can't apply to an
association okay what I'm saying so if I
say chef at at Association I don't know
okay that's correct okay but so that's
what it would have to do yeah so it's
probably not that useful but a way of
seeing map thread is pass an outer and
then an inner so I wonder whether if we
separate these steps okay listen I think
this should be studied but not right
here um Ethan on our live stream is
talking about a function call this index
by Association comma a which would give
but we don't see what it gives that is
fast operators to index and D index
tables
why isn't that just
position effectively what is indexed by
oh I
index by what does that mean does that
or isn't that some kind of key map thing
I really understand that I don't know
please please give us more indication um
let's move on so this should be studied
but we don't know where it's gonna go
yet oh my gosh this is a big can of
worms this is the failure at versus
dollar failed verses these are
definitely open in that post v-12
discussion so if I think we should
postpone that but I think we should I
mean for this particular one we need the
big inventory of where is dollar fail
that cetera used and the absurd um you
know version 0.9 you know internal
variable dollar dollar luxury yacht
which was an early which was worth
luxury yacht yes it was an early thing
added as a hack to avoid various kinds
of things
I doubt it still extant in anyway but it
wasn't it was an earlier kind of hack
for internal use of dollar failed it's
just a joke um Steven before before you
went away if you can let me say for a
second I want to know yeah actually I
want to show what but Ethan on our live
stream is oh yes um so that's the output
from I'm completely mystified here isn't
this like associate well I guess I need
to see what the input is but this is
something where you're taking a list of
associations and you're giving a value
in index value here I'm a little
confused what's the input
okay well I'll get paps in a moment
all right let's what's the what's this
listen we have another issue with
options okay in the function repository
we don't have a good solution for how to
deal with options because you know other
than creating a resource symbol type
thing and having the options in resource
functions be their own resource symbols
which seems very grotesque we don't have
a good way of of what well I mean we
don't have a good way of having I mean
let's let me show you some Horrors here
um because I mean I had some meeting
with the resource function people like
three months ago and they even agreed to
like a 10:00 a.m. meeting and you know I
told him if they need a way to dispatch
off of resource function options of the
resource function that's pretty easy to
do I mean it's a little bit well how do
they represent where's a good example
here I'm trying to find one which had
one of these um but I found one
immediately yesterday
oh gosh swish my hair do you remember
what what the horror that I found
yesterday was wrong okay thank you okay
was a complete horror there where
they're hijacking a system symbol to use
it as an option okay
so the question is what should be done
here so one possible is to string
options which I don't like it all
another possibility is to introduce a
resource symbol but that's also kind of
grotesque so what are the options for
what to do here as in the name of the
option well as in the option receptive
resource function option associated to
these name well I mean why can't it just
be Joe random symbol what context would
it be in doesn't matter what do you mean
yeah well I mean if they if they write
their code correctly using option value
and and such that it doesn't care about
the context it only cares about the name
okay I don't think they know that I
didn't know that actually over on show I
designed that years ago um okay so in
other words they could just have random
symbol names there hmm
it's a little weird because they will
show up in a user's you know global
context probably I mean the problem is
the that options are not scoped the same
ways as to assuming possibilities if
them the context is met I mean we could
introduce the new context just for
options
and then we could just throw everything
in there and it would be in research
percent well but I understand that I
mean because how do we know you know one
of the functions and the function
repository could have a second argument
that's a rule how do we know it's an
option
on the left-hand side come on it has to
declare the options right I always do
options for function repository objects
get attached in some way I think they
currently have some up value on options
to make that work even though as I said
they had some early morning meeting with
them and told them yeah we can actually
do this properly very easily wait a
minute so you're saying so if I take
this function here mm-hm
and I say options of that Wow how the
heck does that work well they have an up
tell you on options of resource function
which okay fine okay
the issue here is okay I mean first the
first bug here of course sushma is that
there's no documentation that mentions
anything about the options but let's not
worry about that but the real question
is how should they set up these options
so you're suggesting that they just use
kind of unidentified flying symbols
basically that's my initial instinct I
mean personally I would use strings yeah
but we've tried to avoid using strings
four options elsewhere in the system
right I mean but from camelcase
in the resource function there is a
string yes yeah awesome
functions these are something else but
it's a little weird because there'll be
strings some options will be
grandfathered from the main system
context and they will be symbols and
some will happen to be you know local to
these functions and they will be strings
and that's pretty ugly right well so
right now the code in unlike option you
know option value mean even option cue
options
assuming assumes assumes that the left
hand side oven of the valid option is
either a string or a symbol okay why
didn't that work that's even a bug in
the camel on and the camel ah but anyway
um okay all right so now the question
would be if I put two lowercase arrow
true I mean if you use the general
options framework it doesn't matter if
it's a string assemble what context the
symbol is in okay so they're using that
presumably well I don't know whether the
code we have to look at the source code
here for this to see what it's doing
right so they've got
pattern options below you you can just
should do back tech to lowercase and
yeah and it should also work I mean
there should be a way to declare an
option here in this source without
having to decide where it goes because
that's something we can decide what are
you saying no I mean there should be a
way to declare an option for that
function without having to me to decide
whether you want to use a system symbol
string or so you just declare an option
name to lowercase and leave it to us to
implement it either by turning it into a
symbol in some context or treating it
internally as a string well I mean Roman
it looks like it is I mean that at the
bottom of that definition is options of
from K it is a system symbol here at the
right hand side should probably be a
string but no no I'm saying we should be
able to process you know if we decide we
want to do something mm-hmm you know
we're already turning that from
camelcase symbol into well here's the
question if I did this right yes I would
I mean we should promote this and we can
still turn this into a symbol but if we
well what happens is a symbol what
happens here option value should that'll
be a string no you can mix and match
then if I say from camelcase here
yeah but yes I mean if you use a symbol
in the source of that function then you
create that simpler yes if you use a
string then you are not committed I
understand so that worked now what
happens if I stringify it's even
documented if you look at the option
value okay hold on what happens if I do
this that's really really weird
I don't know work Oh to lowercase Oh God
that's a different use of to lowercase
yes that's completely crazy
Wow okay well so this is really just a
convention for how people write these
things right I mean and the thing is is
that if you put it in you know some
context then you're going to see that
context we need two options of the
resource function unless that context is
on path sorry say that again what right
so if we said you know that we defined
the options of frame from camel case as
you know resource option backtick lower
case Q or something that probably exists
also goes to true or false okay then
when you do options of your resource
function like you did it was that 29
line 29 you're going to see that context
unless that context is also on dollar
context fast for some reason well you're
arguing against I'm arguing against
putting options in arbitrary contexts as
I think that's gonna look worse than
just using strings right but okay the
question really is how do we document in
the function repository how do we
document options because unlike in our
main documentation where options are
symbols and they have their own
reference pages we don't want to be that
heavyweight for the function repository
right but I thought the whole point of
function repository functions was that
they all will fit on one page so what
does it matter if they're strings or not
you have a tape or somebody return one
page what are we talking about that that
the document right these are supposed to
be simple one-liner implemented as one
line but they're there documentation is
cut-and-dried doesn't have a lot of
tentacles right so you have a table of
you know you have an option section with
examples or you have a table of string
options and that's it I mean okay but
the question is are they string options
or are they symbol options that are
documented that I would have the code
that generates the resource object force
everything in the same in their strings
even if there are all are already system
symbols that's really funky one question
do we want users to use the same option
for the same objective or they can use
the same option for defensins no it
should obviously they should try and
just like you could you know you could
use the word turtle to represent
something that isn't a turtle but it
will be a foolish thing to do I mean
that was a silly example but you know
what I'm saying you can you know I mean
I I'm immediately thinking of a million
examples where people use a word like
I'm thinking the word chair what other
meaning could that possibly have except
some kind of fancy professorship so the
question is whether we need a list of
all the options so that users make sure
that they are not reusing an option in a
different way then yes I see what you're
saying if we use string options then
they could be reusing what is other word
in other places a symbol option but
using it for a different purpose and
then each option is documented in each
page in its own way I'm gonna have to go
I'm sorry what if they're using an
already documented option then obviously
it has its own documentation so two
users may define options with the same
name but they have different purposes in
mind and it'll be fine
if those are created or something what I
mean so suppose you had your functions
you know as an option you use the name
near the string degree you know so in
one place it's an interpolation order
sort of thing and somewhere else it's
temperature thing or something yeah okay
so the main point you're making is
because we don't have global design you
know for the function repository there
is no global design oversight therefore
that can happen we could have you know
whole giant colony of of uses of an
option for one thing which eventually
will collide with uses for another thing
and you know each function has its own
options because this is one function at
a time type work exactly we worry about
not in the same name for a function but
the options we don't go yeah I think
that's the right answer but then the
question is what do we tell people to do
and how do we document it so we could
tell them if you are using okay so you
know one possibility is that we say
documented as if they're symbols so that
it so that if you happen to have an
option which agrees with an existing
system option first you'll notice that
and second of all the documentation will
link to it okay if I mean oh and we've
already done this ourselves we have them
a tiny number of options that don't have
their own documentation pages but
nevertheless their system symbols but so
in this case what we would say is
implement our strings document as
symbols
does that make sense when you say
documented symbols you mean having their
separate pages no I don't mean have a
separate page I just mean on the page on
the page for the function have the table
not have quotes in it okay yeah yeah
okay I think the only slight problem is
if I then use that function and I use
the option without the quotes it'll work
it will work and that symbol will end up
in global or so yeah right okay that I
think that's fine yes because it doesn't
yeah I think that's fine yes yeah all
right I think good looks good
institutional can you communicate that
to the function repository folk yeah I
think that's very good actually and it
can be part of the validation step to
check the people have defined their
options which are not system symbols as
strings yeah I actually like this
solution I mean it's a bit of a hack but
there's no choice but to have a bit of a
hack because this is a you know that's
an ad hoc thing so right um okay
interesting comment from Brian on the
livestream that camel kept from camel
cases to location should make all the
words lowercase and other options such
as title case could make the first
letter of the first word capitalized I
agree right I mean whether there should
be a conversion function option okay see
this is the slippery slope on which we
live with the function repository I'm
saying if we were designing it it would
be yes I understand
um and okay but what Brian's comment
effectively raises for us and there's
more discussion with Sushma here is you
know what is our mechanism for users to
give design commentary on these things
and do we have a good way of doing that
discussion because you know it could be
I mean we've got a fair number of these
functions it could be somebody looks at
this particularly people who've you know
been involved in these live streams
certainly know what our process is and
you know if people could give useful
comments on these functions you know
given that when
doing this whole process for all these
functions that's the whole point you
know what's our mechanism for you know
providing that you know having designed
discussion about these functions and
feeding it back to the authors have we
thought of perfect no we're not talking
about it I mean there is a give feedback
in the in the page but we don't have
like interactive sessions with oh this
is stupid
please do we need to fix this I mean
this is really stupid if I might say so
so much of this were like wasn't Earth
with a phone number be good for here no
did we went through the student way a
few weeks ago socially yeah yeah I mean
that's that's something Bob deals with
not I think I went through what this
should say yeah it shouldn't be this
could we link it to the community yes I
think it would be a fine thing to do and
have yeah okay so that's a question for
Vitaly if somebody if one says discuss
this function on community mm-hmm how
should that work could creative
appropriate topic topic and then a
thread and then the first time somebody
does that okay so that's a reasonable
way to do it so what would happen is
discuss this on community if it already
exists if there's already a thread
tagged to this function then it would
just you know you just be taken there if
there isn't a thread it would create a
new one right so I think it's a good
idea that's the right place to out it
yeah fair enough so this so then every
function we've brought shouldn't
probably preemptively create a thread on
community for every single function
repository item but there should be a
way if there is such a thread to
immediately jump to it from this page
and and that would also be useful to
people who are trying to use this
function because there might be comments
about it on that thread I like that idea
sandir is pointing out that MathWorks
has a function repository yeah I'm sure
they copied it from our thing called
math sauce from 1989 umm which we didn't
ever think was very successful um and
they have a discussion thread yeah I'm
sure the uh I think um um okay actually
Ethan is asking the question why is the
resource function icon an open circle
yes that question has been raised by
other people and I thought we were
getting a design that involved it not
being an open circle because I think the
open circles are confusing
wasn't that Sushma wasn't that something
yeah I'm going and some design specs for
that we have to look back on that again
we didn't did we conclude on something
or not no we did not conclude on
anything that can that can happen in our
next meeting right the function of posit
or interestingly math sauce yeah math
sauce is a lesson was not a function
repository it's just a random put in any
random piece of blob of code you want
and that wasn't very successful now
hopefully we are also about to have a
public padlet repository which again is
more of a you know you can install
anything type thing but I personally
think the function repository is going
to be easier for most people in the
packet system which will only be for
people who are pro doing pretty
professional software development it's
my view and also the packet system will
allow you know can elaborate updating
and forking and so on things where as
the function repository is pretty much
well there's a version and you can
update it to a new version and so on and
you'll be getting the newest version
whenever you use it all right let's some
if we're ready to wrap up the nation my
screen no because we're going to talk
about
Ethan's comments about his some okay the
input is this association let's go back
here okay so he's saying um
that is an interesting operation
I mean we could imagine that also for a
list
that you take out the enth element here
and that becomes
yeah
that's an interesting operation I think
I mean people understand what this what
this is
well the one thing it can immediately
become is a function repository entry
and if he thing has already implemented
this and that's a great thing to do with
it
um as far as the system symbol is
concerned it requires more work but at
the very least we could have that do
people understand this operation yeah
seems like an interesting operation to
me um it's like what happens in a
database where you say index by this
somebody's typing is very audible
okay also Ethan is raising the question
of transpose with
what does this do in fact right now
yeah the transpose transpose of a list
an association what have we concluded
about that
I mean it still needs to we should
support it with a loud heads but the
implementation is not done and I mean
this particular case you might be able
to to use allowed heads goes to all I
think to make it work but you know this
is a very simple case and I mean the
reason we oh yeah the reason it's not
documented yet is that there are lots of
cases that that don't work so okay okay
okay um there's one more thing on our
live stream here
just look for that and then we should
probably wrap up here particularly happy
with the progress here on how to think
about options for the function posit or
that's good um
okay so a few items from this on this
notebook actually it's being saved in a
really random place and I'm just gonna
send it to Sushma here okay all right
well thank you all um this might be our
last livestream and in other words our
last livestream let me look um of the
season Steven tonight okay all right
okay actually there's another live
stream tomorrow talking about finance
documentation um hold on one second um
[Music]
um yes go ahead
so this is sort of uh propose nothing
but well I guess it's a little early
Christmas present for you and other Mac
users that they've spent way too much
time over the last week doing so I have
Mathematica old here and Mathematica new
here which started life as the same
layout and Mathematica old is being a
little bit slow but oh no did my yes and
there we go and that we get the scary
message saying that Mathematica old is
not optimized for your Mac and needs to
be updated because it has a few things
I'm just amazed that having come out in
Hebrew works at all
yes so then Mathematica knew is the same
thing but has a couple of what basically
it has one updated binary which XML and
so the pull request was just approved
this morning and so it'll be internet oh
that's my friends with no scary warning
very nice the warning is even scarier
well it has fonts I can't read um all
right so that that's my Christmas
present to all those Mac users out there
yeah that's very good very nice very
nice um okay great
all right so thanks all thanks to the
folks on the livestream talk to you all
soon